this is a Fox News Alert on Bret Baier
in Washington we have two FoxNews
exclusives tonight Bill Hemmer is
traveling with the Attorney General and
El Salvador and has William Barnes first
interview in that role Barr has
questions about the origins of the
Russia investigation and is vowing to
get to the bottom of it we will get to
that in just a moment but first our
other exclusive an interview with the
brother of former national security
adviser Michael Flynn who is back in the
news after a federal judge ordered parts
of the Muller report to be unredacted
and made public in the criminal case
against Michael Flynn it's the first
time a federal judge has ordered the
Justice Department to make public
portions of the report the agency had
kept secret chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
been following this case from the
beginning and has this interview could
even Catherine Thank You Brett and good
evening confirmation that the FBI
investigation of Mike Flynn began
earlier than previously reported
blindsided his family Joe Flynn says
it's evidence of a long-running
high-level effort to quote trip up and
trap his brother as a federal judge
orders the release of more secret
documents new special counsel records
show former national security adviser
Mike Flynn reported multiple instances
before and after his guilty plea where
he or his lawyers got calls from
individuals connected to the
administration or Congress quote that
could have affected both his willingness
to cooperate and the completeness of
that cooperation the defendant even
provided a voicemail recording of one
such communication sources close to the
matter tell Fox Flynn had a joint
defense agreement with the president's
legal team and after Flynn began
cooperating with the special counsel the
president's lawyers plan to protect
privileged material oh is it absolute
surprise speaking exclusively to Fox
Flynn's brother is reacting to the
Muller report and a key section
indicating the retired general was
already under FBI investigation during
the 2016 presidential transition general
Flynn went through 19 sessions with the
special counsel approximately 90 hours
of torturous interviews and this never
came up the entire time buried in volume
2 the report states that investigators
came across the FBI probe while
examining quote Flynn
of sanctions with Russian ambassador
kiss lyac previously the FBI had opened
an investigation of Flynn based on his
relationship with the Russian government
Flynn's contacts with kiss lyac became a
key component of that investigation that
timing matters because it was previously
thought
Flynn's phone calls with kiss lyac that
led to Flint's termination for lying
prompted the FBI case a 27 year Justice
Department veteran reviewed the passage
it looks pretty clear to me that the use
of the word previously is suggesting an
independent investigation footnotes cite
FBI interviews known as a 302 with
former acting assistant attorney general
Mary McCord who helped steer the Russia
probe and former FBI director James
Comey the president tweeted it now seems
general Flynn was under investigation
long before was common knowledge why was
I not told so that I could make a change
Flynn's brother says the passage backs
up the family's long-held concerns
because of his vocal criticism of the
Obama administration and specifically
the intelligence community which he came
out of my suspicion is that they were
doing everything they could to trip him
up and to trap him the reference to
Russian government contacts
maybe this 2015 Moscow dinner where
Flint sat next to the Russian president
but Joe Flynn says his brother who had
led military intelligence kept them in
the loop he briefed the DIA prior to
that and he briefed the DIA after that
the House Republican Russia report found
there was no FBI briefing warning the
Trump campaign that the bureau was
running a counterintelligence case on
Flynn the special counsels office
declined to comment for our reporting
Brett more to come on this captain thank
you